coming up on top chef family style game
time baby please join us in welcoming
the la rams draft class
welcome to the top chef family style
kitchen arena flip it turn it cut it
let's go i'm scared
you can't put fresh garlic in that don't
hurt nobody we're leaving
there's a lot that can go wrong did you
put any salt no how well we get along
decides how well we'll do in the
competition why can't you just give me
credit the hollandaise isn't going to
make it where is it where is it i'm
crying
again
let's make this thing move like a
symphony
whoa i didn't even know things good days
like this
i was like oh let me go on in here i'm
so excited he said i'm so excited which
is very jessie spano of you
i love truffle well you are very
high-end i'm so impressed with the
caliber here we kill those competing
hand to hand with somebody you love is a
wonderful thing it's so damn good i
didn't expect that i'm gonna hire all of
you what's the hourly pay
[Laughter]
the chefs are never gonna believe what
we have planned for their next challenge
you